many Americans are ringing in the New
Year with a new round of resolutions
this morning we're joined by a team of
experts with tips to improve your
finances your health and tech practices
in 2020 and we're gonna start with money
one survey of financial resolutions
finds 53% of Americans hope to save more
in 2020
51% hope to pay down debt and 35% hope
to spend less in the new year CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with how to make those goals happen
Jill Happy New Year and happy New Year
to you so how do we get this started you
know we all starts with how much money
is coming into your household how much
is going out I know that sounds kind of
simple but this is really not about
budgeting it's about tracking the money
and without understanding that it's
really hard to prioritize your finances
so one thing to consider is to download
an app there are tons out there lots of
free ones mint or clarity money and it
helps you organize what you are doing
that way you'll have a way to at least
figure out what's most important and how
much money you have to do these things
yeah and you say we should embrace
technology when it comes to paying bills
what do you mean well you can set lots
of dates automatically so for example
let's say you've got an outstanding
credit card balance maybe you went crazy
over the holidays you want to establish
an automatic payment on a certain date
maybe you want to set aside a certain
amount of money for savings you can do
that as well what we're really trying to
do is time when you get money in and
then set the date when it's going out
and what's really important about this
is by doing this you may be able to save
yourself a lot of fees and headaches and
that you're making a commitment as well
to making those payments absolutely you
say this is a good time to think even
beyond the new year how so I know that
none of us woke up this morning saying I
wonder what it's gonna happen when I die
okay I get that that you're not doing
that but I am asking you and I'm going
down on bent knee and and really begging
all of you to consider finishing these
tasks that are very hard to do so estate
planning is one of these big issues that
always looms large everyone says I know
I need to do it so let's commit to doing
it let's try to figure out a will a
power of attorney a hell
care proxy letters of instruction you
know where most people get tripped up
they can't figure out who's gonna be the
Guardian for their kid yeah pick the
best possible choice you can both agree
on get that on paper get that happening
try to get that retirement plan started
up that's a long way in the future and
get these things done so you don't have
to ponder this three months from now
yeah it's something we all put off but
it gives you a lot of peace of mind
absolutely all right Jill Schlesinger
Thanks
you